retro racking tour here guys just a dad
who loves games and the stories they
tell we got the Hogwarts theme tree
ready to go Thanksgiving is over and we
are officially entering the Christmas
season and hey Hogwarts Legacy fans we
get a little bit of a gift early here
courtesy of avalanche software just when
I was getting ready to shut down the
studio for the night it is about 1:44
a.m. for me I've been recording videos
playing games recording gameplay I
thought you know what let's head over to
WB Games and let's just see if they've
got any new hires posted and what do you
know here I spot this glorious new
posting for a senior producer now you
may be thinking retro what's the big
deal here I promise this is going to be
a quick video we're going to get right
to the point here because this one
mentions Hogwarts Legacy directly which
I don't believe we have seen it happen
quite like this before they've mentioned
the team who worked on Hogwarts like
Legacy and other things like that
however this one just straight up says
seeks a senior producer to join the
Hogwarts Legacy team right there clear
as can be and then if you back up here
join the team behind the Blockbuster
open world action RPG Hogwarts Legacy as
we create what next so not one but two
mentions of Hogwarts Legacy right there
now if you're going to get really
technical maybe you could say well it
doesn't actually confirm that they're
working on more Hogwarts Legacy However
the fact that they're calling it the
Hogwarts Legacy team certainly indicates
very strongly at least to me that we are
getting more Hogwarts Legacy which is
not a surprise at all I think the
biggest question now is what is that is
it going to be some type of major
expansion to the core game that we
already have is it the sequel that we
won't see for a number of years now
anytime I do a video like this people
always say hey I want the sequel just go
and work on it and I'm like do you guys
really want to wait like four or five
years or would you rather get something
like in a year maybe instead I'm still
in that boat man I I want to see more
from this game I think they've built an
incredible world and with some added
expansions to really develop that story
even more they could do something really
really special and also be working on
the sequel hey you made over a billion
dollars right let's hire a new team
let's have one team working on DLC and
expansions have the other team making
the sequel and we'll just have this
beautiful happy moment here for Hogwarts
Legacy fans guys I said it was going to
be quick that's going to be it for me
YouTube thinks this video over here on
the right left I don't know whatever
side of this grade it's on YouTube
thinks that would be a good one for you
to check out next as always thank you
all so much for watching talk to you
again soon